Lake Shelton has said that he has a man  crush on you he wants to kiss you and he  thinks you're sexy how do you feel about  that I feel violated by that yeah  he's sexually attracted to me he wants  to have sex with me for sure so it's not  just a man it's not a man no do you  think he actually wants to do the deed  with you like I have platonic love for  him really he's a wonderful man but  sexually it's just not he's not my type  I guess because he's a guy or not the  right guy mostly because he's a guy yeah  you know but he's just really it makes  me uncomfortable when he hugs me he hugs  me for like a like a second or two too  long doesn't want to let go right and  and it makes me feel weird but I endure  that because you know he's great he's a  great guy so he whisper in your ear hold  me forever has he ever done he whispers  things in my ear but that's not hers  this would be the ultimate crossover it  would be do the ultimate crossover  you